[Applause]
thousands of migrants set out from the
city of tapachula in the early hours of
monday
many are mothers with young children who
despite the heavy rain push to keep pace
with the rest of the crowd
there's numerous nationalities among
them but the vast majority are from
venezuela
all want to reach the united states
i left my country in search of a better
future with god's help if he permits i
will reach the u.s border and find new
opportunities and help my family
it's already been a long and difficult
journey for most
and many are now finding that mexico has
its own challenges
for this elderly woman the inclement
weather is too much
fortunately paramedics are close by
her daughter says they're desperate for
the nightmare to be over
we're hoping they'll give us u.s visa
there are many of us migrants here we
need help just like this woman there are
many people here children and disabled
people who get tired many people died in
the jungle on our way here pregnant
women children there are children who
fainted just behind us
it's the largest migrant caravan to set
out from southern mexico this year
but for a group this size to stay
together frequent rests are needed
especially for families traveling with
young children
after several hours of walking the group
has taken a break from the punishing
heat of southern mexico they're tired
you can see the exhaustion on many of
their faces but just about everyone
we've spoken to says they're also
committed to continuing their journey to
the u.s southern border
with more rain forecast the decision has
been made for the group to stay put
they'll rest for now but the plan is to
take to the road again after midnight
and make it as far as they can before
the heat sets in once again manuel
rapalo al jazeera chiapas mexico